how's it going everybody welcome back to
the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and today we have some news about some
exciting projects coming at Marvel
Studios right now currently there are
many different sides of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe being set up when the
MCU first started mostly everything was
kind of contained to Earth even Thor who
was from Asgard spent a lot of his time
on Earth in his films with the exception
of Thor Ragnarok but pretty much from
the very first Iron Man film up until
Avengers end game the MCU was pretty
contained it was pretty much contained
to the Avengers and the Guardians of the
Galaxy kind of only having one or two
different sides however Kevin feige the
president of the Marvel Studios has come
out recently over the past few years and
stated a few different times that the
MCU was going to have many different new
sides to it we'll have the Earth team
the grounded team or what Kevin feige is
referred to as the street level team
then we're gonna have the supernatural
side this has been introduced more and
more recently with Doctor Strange in the
Multiverse of Madness werewolf By Night
One Division kind of fits into this
category as well and then of course we
have shows coming like Agatha coven of
chaos and movies like blade then we have
the more Cosmic side the where love and
thunder showed us a literal Cosmic
entity eternity the Guardians of the
Galaxy of course pushed the cosmic side
as well and then with films like the
Marvels and the next eternals film
coming out we're gonna see more of the
cosmos and hopefully fingers crossed
more Cosmic entities so a lot of
exciting things are being set up right
now and today we have news about two
projects that are going to fit inside of
two different categories today we'll be
talking about a young Avengers project
which is also going to be a spin-off of
One Division and we'll be talking about
Nova there's a little bit of bad news on
this front for Nova but also some good
news as well but don't worry we're gonna
break down everything you need to know
in this video and if you want to stay up
to date on the MCU be sure to subscribe
and hit that notification Bell also
subscribe and leave a comment to
automatically be entered in our giveaway
for a chance to win an Xbox series X the
PS5 some Marvel Legends items or some DC
items we pick a winner at the end of
each month and the winner picks one item
so before we dive into this new one
division spin-off Young Avengers project
let's just talk about Nova because
Unfortunately today we've heard a little
bit of bad news Insider my time to shine
hello who has an excellent track record
with Scoops replied to a tweet asking
the question where the hell is my Nova
show slash movie in which my time to
shine responded with the Nova show has
been scrapped they are now focusing on
other stuff and will get back to Nova
down the line now obviously this is
unfortunate news we have heard reports
for a while now stating that Nova is
getting his own project we knew it most
likely wasn't going to be a movie and
some websites even reported that it was
going to be a Disney plus special
presentation just to introduce Nova
introduce the character how Nova gets
its powers a little bit of a backstory
and then Nova would appear in other
movies and other shows but from what my
time to shine hello said it was going to
be a show so it sucks that the show is
now delayed or scrapped for the meantime
but it is good news that they are going
to get back to Nova down the line and
it's also not so bad because Nova still
could appear in another project just
because Nova's own show has been
scrapped for the time being doesn't mean
that Marvel Studios still doesn't have
plans for him in fact there are many
different story lines that he could fit
into in the MCU currently right now plus
not to mention Avengers Infinity war did
set up Nova Thor mentioned that Thanos
decimated xandar well if there was one
survivor of the Nova Corps he would get
the full power of the Nova Force turning
him into the hero Nova so just because
we haven't seen him yet doesn't mean
that he's not out there and we even
heard a lot of casting reports about
Nova as well such as Ryan Gosling was
wanted by Marvel Studios to play Nova
and Kevin feige has even mentioned one
time that he would love for Ryan Gosling
to be in the MCU so perhaps they were
looking into Nova but since Disney plus
and Marvel Studios are kind of changing
their plans right now for Disney plus
content and since we have the actor
strike and the rider strike going on
right now and a lot already happening
with Bass Live and phase six perhaps
they just decided to push this to the
side for now but again it doesn't mean
that they can't have Nova appear in
another show or another film so don't
lose hope on Nova yet specifically when
it comes to those Cosmic projects like
the marbles or perhaps a new Guardians
of the Galaxy movie Nova could
definitely show up but on the other hand
the other project that I was speaking of
the Young Avengers project the wand
division spin-off is a Supernatural
Project and it's going to be about a
young Avenger slash Wanda's son Wiccan
or as we know him from One Division
Billy but we did see him during the
Halloween episode dress up as the comic
accurate version of wicked also his
brother has speed as well and we've
learned that Marvel Studios has some
pretty big plans for this kid not just
for his own series but for the upcoming
Young Avengers project as well we'll
explain everything but first big thank
you to bird dogs for sponsoring this
video If you struggle with finding good
shorts to wear ones that actually fit
and actually look good the struggle is
over bird dogs make you look good and
they are extreme family comfortable bird
dogs are specifically designed to look
slimmer on the thigh and the leg giving
you a sculpted look and the best part is
they are stretch khaki shorts they do
the exact same thing as Lululemon but
they fit way better most shorts out
there don't fit very well they're pretty
restricting they're stiff the cotton
they use is pretty terrible but bird
dogs fixes this issue by inventing Cloud
knit fabric that looks just like khaki
but stretches so you get a way Slimmer
fit without having to sacrifice movement
they also use anti-stink sweat weakening
fabric that helps keep you cool and dry
all day long I've personally really
struggled with shorts because I'm not a
tall guy and I'm kind of bulky and I
have not been able to find shorts that
aren't too long that actually allow me
to move but now I have with bird dogs
they are awesome and the best part is if
you order a pair you get a free Yeti
style tumbler so go to birddogs.com
Cosmic for a free Yeti style tumbler
with your order that's birddogs.com
Cosmic for a free Yeti style tumbler you
won't want to take your bird dogs off we
promise you according to Insider Daniel
rpk a Wiccan Billy show was in
development at Marvel Studios pre-strike
this would Mark the third one division
spin-off following Agatha coven of chaos
and Vision Quest both of which should be
coming relatively soon now something to
know about Wiccan Billy and his future
with the Marvel Cinematic Universe is
that from what we know so far about the
Agatha coven of chaos series he's going
to play a pretty major role in that
series no it's not going to be the exact
same version of Billy that we met in one
division but he is going to be a
reincarnated version this is something
that happens in the comics as well Wanda
loses her kids but they are kind of
reincarnated and eventually they do have
a reunion with their mother Wanda but
based off of what we know about Agatha
Covenant of chaos Agatha is kind of
going to be the mother of Billy in that
show not the birth mother but the
adopted mother and apparently neither
are really going to know that billy
slash Wiccan is The Reincarnation of
Wanda Sun Village but it looks like he's
going to have a pretty big role if he's
going to be getting his own Disney plus
spin-off but this does make sense
considering what we know about coven of
chaos Agatha is going to be training him
and what better which to have train you
than Agatha Harkness yeah it would have
been cool if his mom trained him but I'm
sure that's gonna happen down the line
because as we all know the Scarlet Witch
is not dead and I know that if she hears
even a hint of her kids possibly being
alive even if that is a reincarnated
version of them she's definitely gonna
jump on that opportunity to try and go
get them back we have heard a rumor that
Wanda might show up in the last episode
of back of the coven of chaos but this
is just a rumor for now and is in no way
confirmed but perhaps that could set up
the events of the wiccan Disney Plus
show either way we also know that a
Young Avengers project is being set up
right now as well we've already met many
Young Avengers in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe we have Cassie Lane we have
Kate Bishop we have Kamala Khan She-Hulk
just introduced Hulk's son and they're
going to be many more Young Avengers
joining them and I'm sure Billy is going
to join as well maybe even his brother
speed but Wiccan has powers pretty much
just like his mother's plus he's going
to be trained in witchcraft by Agatha
Harkness he is definitely going to be a
big hitter coming up in the MCU
especially when he becomes a full adult
and has fully developed powers and full
control over those Powers he's gonna
become extremely powerful and a big
hitter for the Young Avengers so
hopefully they get back to writing this
show after the strike ends and it's
pretty cool to see that one division set
up so many different things Agatha coven
of chaos Vision Quest and now a series
about Wiccan I think it's pretty cool
but hey let us know what you think about
this in the comments down below are you
excited for this project or not let us
know your thoughts about Nova as well
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest videos you can always
follow us on Instagram and Twitter as
well and as always thank you all so much
for watching wolf